Sexual tastes of vary from person to
person.  But with the current pornography
epidemic as some call it.  One has to
wonder how exactly this may effect our
desires and perception of sexuality.
Moreover, how does it affect our sex
lives.
Pornography constitutes about twenty
five percent of all search engine
requests, and is the fourth most common
reason people give for going on the
internet.  And well may seem to simply
facilitate an instinctual sexual
response linked to millions of years of
evolution.  The truth is pornography has
dynamically changed over time ultimately
molding our tastes and desires.  The not so
shocking truth is that pornography has
profound consequences for the brain and
acts in many ways like a drug.
With prolonged exposure your tolerance is
increased and many often find themselves
addicted.  Though it is not a physical substance,
it leads to the same general loss of
control, the compulsiveness to seek out
the activity despite negative
consequences
and withdrawl when it goes away.  Much like
that of gambling or running for example.
The issue is that continued exposure can
cause long-term or even lifelong neuro-plastic
change in the brain. Dopamine is
released as a reward whenever we
accomplish something whether it be
eating to sustain life or sexual
activity to produce future life.
And this dopamine consolidates neural
connections in order to drive us to
perform the same activity in the future.
In other words, it alters and forms the
brain cells to motivate certain actions.
It rewires your brain.
The national institutes of health
measure drug addictiveness by testing
rats.  The rat is trained to press a button
in order to get a drug, and the harder it
works indicates how addictive the
substance is.  It turns out that the
more addictive a drug is the more to
dopamine we see released.
And while there is unfortunately no rat porn
that we can give to them, we do know that
dopamine is also released during sexual
excitement which pornography plays right
into.  The more time you spend doing it,
the more dopamine gets released which
reinforces the behavior and makes you
not only desire it in the future but
require it.  And as you begin to imagine
these images away from the computer or
while having sex, they become reinforced.
Furthermore each orgasm releases even
more dopamine which consolidates the
connections made during the session.  It's
a feedback loop that becomes harder to
escape and just like a drug your
tolerance for visual stimulation has now
compounded, making it more difficult to be
turned on by reality.  Pornography
addiction can often lead to finding your
mate less attractive, the good news is
it doesn't have to be permanent.  Usually
when people understand the mechanism and
realize it's affecting their
relationships, they can stop.
The brain is often described as a use
it or lose it system because the neural
connections you stimulate grow
stronger and desire to be activated while
the ones you ignore become weakened.
Much like your muscles which if sitting
still all day itch for activity but
after prolonged non-use they become
complacent.  Luckily, because of this "use it
or lose it" brain, the same neuro-plastic
system that proliferate these habits can
also be used to acquire healthier ones.
Got a burning question you wanr answered?
Asking it in the comments or on facebook and twitter.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos.